the simple question is do you believe in  equal pay  [Music]  he's answered this so many times kathy  yeah  oh i made the argument there so it  depends  no i'm not saying that at all because a  lot of people listening to you will just  say i mean are we going back to the  doctor you're actually not listening i'm  just being pretty carefully and i'm  hearing you basically  are you listening very carefully because  are you kathy you have asked him things  like oh so you don't believe in he's  like i never said that oh so would you  celebrate that why why wouldn't he i  don't think you're listening to me i  don't think she's listening at all she  wants to get her  her questions out and her point